hey how's it going written my name is
Peter back welcome back to another
episode of The Walking Dead and the last
one we met at some new group of people
not all of them seem too happy to meet
us but let's see what Clem is if she's
like gem to my friends here we are
godless that's a great doctor right
there just [ __ ] touch oh this might
hurt a little
I think it's nothing compared to what
she will do there suturing skills needs
some work otherwise I say she should be
fine
so it wasn't a lurker bite if it was the
fever would have already set in and her
temperature would be through the roof oh
he's so angry now cuz he was wrong
[ __ ] idiot
let me look so badass I really like her
in this season I mean I like him both
but I was I didn't do anything I didn't
do anything exactly what Sara says every
time I catch her in a lie we put you in
that shed out of concern for the safety
of our loved ones and then you escaped
and persuaded my daughter to steal from
us and it had in henan a I'll give you
the benefit of the doubt but there are a
few things you need to know about my
daughter okay why is it like you you may
not get that initially but once you're
around her for a while you'll understand
I don't even mean who how bad the world
is oh there she would cease to function
she's my little girl she's all I have
left and I would ask that you stay away
from her this is gonna end bad
soon as he grabbed some time to grow up
sometimes you do not know what she needs
sorry sorry I don't know anything
Rebecca was worried you might be working
with someone else
that your being here was no accident I
guess we'll find out but one thing I
know for sure you are not to be trusted
oh thanks thanks Carlos stay away from
my daughter
hey uh brought you some food if you're
hungry
it's a tacos
is it tacos
there's literally nothing on that
student leave one hell of a scar
doesn't bother me I can live with it Wow
nice claim is badass now gross
how's that guy's problem
Hey look
I don't say I'm sorry for for being a
dick out there I got kind of aggro that
was definitely not cool
next been known to go off every once in
a while don't hold it against him yeah I
guess we all have our moments you
definitely had one out there okay
protecting your friends I get it
I didn't mean to be so harsh I just we
had a bad experience once we all had bad
experiences all had bad experiences
but it's that blueberry cold place we
took care of someone who got dead it was
my fault it was no one's fault
we thought we could control it but we
couldn't and then she turned and his mom
was standing right there she got
attacked this isn't that hard just punch
him in the face
hopefully you understand
bad things that happened everyone
so since you're pretty much on your own
what's your plan I guess if we don't
really have one I don't know I'm kind of
on my own now well you're welcome to
stay here if you want okay let yourself
heal up take some time to sort things
out
do you think everyone else will be okay
with it they'll just have to deal with
it Oh
so what happened to your parents if you
don't mind me asking what does he think
I mean I assume what happened to them is
what happened to just about everyone's
parents just so young didn't think he
could have made it on your own for so
long but maybe people other people took
care of me if that's what you're asking
I was just curious on how he made it
this far I just tried to stay with good
people and not do anything dumb
Hey I'm sorry I shouldn't have asked
it's okay
try to find them my parents went on
vacation and loved me with a babysitter
and they never came back we went to
Savannah to find them but they were
already dead well I'm sorry to hear that
and she mainly this man found me and
took care of me we met up with other
survivors and we all tried to make it
but it didn't work
his name was Lee only how to survive he
taught me how to shoot a gun what
happened to him
the same thing that happens to everyone
but he saved me first lots of times you
know sounds like he was a real good guy
it was the master now bring back
memories
I hate dinner up but I'm out there stand
and watch and I can't help but notice
this place is lit up like a goddamn
beacon in the middle of the woods yeah
it's time to turn in anyways I'll get
your winks while you can cuz we're going
fishing at first light
a couple fresh brookey's for dinner
wouldn't happy nice yeah I would be nice
don't know what at brookie is been as ly
number two I'm sure they look identical
she ever gonna finish that no you're
still here I'm polish that food ain't
going anywhere
oh I know something about you lady
Oh mrs. sass queen is at it that banana
in a jar
Luke invited me to stay good for him but
that's not how things work around here
we make decisions as a group and you're
wearing out you're welcome
you've got what you came here for
now go [ __ ]
[ __ ] cow how dare she how bad she
talked to Clementine like hey hey I got
an achievement
we're gonna fit all week oh I thought
Clementine was holding patience but
those are her arms how you holding up
I heard you got an earful from Rebecca
last night once she gets going there's
no bringing her back I'm not scared of
her sighs seeing this she's all talk she
doesn't scare me she was in a mood last
night that's for sure how far are these
fish traps it ain't much further anyone
teach you how to shoot come on whether
that's not proper any idiot where the
finger can shoot yeah but not a rifle
well that makes sense let's kick this
thing it'd probably knock you on your
ass what Nick was about your age first
time I took him huntin came across this
beautiful 13-point buck just standing
there on the ridgeline the boy takes the
rifle he lines up the shot just like I
taught him and then I hear him start
whining he turns to me and he says I
can't do it I can't shoot at Uncle Pete
please don't make me shoot it
really no way nice to met you that I
said wait wait I don't wanna see today
I'm around while you piss on a tree you
know where the river is boy anyway so I
grabbed the gun out of his hand before
the big buck runs off when bang the gun
fires boy nearly gut shot me and of
course the buck gets away what are you
going and telling her this [ __ ] for yeah
as you almost blew her face off
yesterday seems relevant trying to let
her know it's nothing personal with you
why are you always giving me a hard time
because you're always giving everyone
else a hard time I apologized already
she accepted it's fine he said he
apologized you're always trying to
embarrass me you're doing a good enough
job of that on your own god
leaving us again I know where the
[ __ ] River is damn those guys have
some issues so anyway and somebody's
howling later that season shot it right
in the neck brought it up to my sister's
figure and she'd want to freeze some of
the meat Nick didn't speak to me for
weeks sometimes you got to play a role
even if it means people you love hate
you for it what does that even mean it
doesn't hate you obviously you should
tell him that you should tell them that
yeah just the right thing here oh oh no
he's gonna die
[ __ ] hell Nick what what is it a
whales a me a zombie whale Oh Jess it is
oh no it isn't whoa whoa are those the
guys I chase us careful now
not sure yet but it ain't your average
gang of thugs that much I know
think about it your Carver what do you
do who's Carver
just libraries there be careful
some of them might still be moving
clammy be careful okay
there's a lot of them what is happening
here okay well I guess we'll check this
one that's a nice jacket just give them
a good old poke that's what I do
this one shot to through the head
yeah check the rest and look for ammo
we're running low well she didn't really
check in for ammo let's talk to Nick for
a second here can I help my god
Oh Milo is a great conversation enjoy
staring at that zombies hair you can't
see that when we're out there this was
no rinky-dink pissin match what was it
yeah what boob our food bar we need to
get the [ __ ] out of here gotta check the
rest what what I calm down and think
about it son calm down we gotta get out
of here now
Jesus Christ get ahold of yourself
someone's alive Nick who cares because
they might just be inclined to tell us
who did this we got to do this now I
don't like this
keep searching these this is a dumb idea
oh no we're gonna get split up I don't
like this either but sooner or later
you're gonna have to realize a simple
truth I don't like this I don't like an
[ __ ] that nobody in this world is
ever gonna give a goddamn whether you
like something or not you gotta grow up
son well he can go to tumblr and tell
people whatever I bet he's going there
right now you want to be useful keep a
lookout on that tree line whoever did
this might still be out there waiting
for another sucker to stumble across
this mess I'd be more useful with a gun
I don't doubt it at some point
you guys have to trust me hell I trust
you but not everyone's at that point yet
given time it's been a day Johnson hang
on stop
oh I hear something
set a polar bear hope this isn't it oh
damn damn it more on that side you check
out these ones see if there's anything
on them that'll tell us who they were
come on go back go back to your son name
something bad it's gonna happen I don't
like he that guy looks happy that one
isn't shot in the head careful he is not
that shut that IME hideout I I didn't
see really no okay well fine have fun I
guess I go to this guy then I should get
this freed no I should not have any
defense at all because I'm a little girl
whoa don't do anything stupid now
claiming clue Clemmy collude
no no claim to Claire bad Clement close
its catalyst no what is it
where the [ __ ] are you always that guy
sorry what happened yeah tell me where's
Krista the woman I was with what
happened to her please tell me tell me
please
nope I give you water after you tell me
you were speaking just fine before now
tell me what happened oh come on Pete
I'm fine I'm fine just just lost my
footing
whoa and then the decision time I don't
want him to die yeah BAM oh right I'm
making all the wrong decisions here I
don't [ __ ] know well god damn it I
can't change
I got damn it all right well [ __ ] it
this is what I chose [ __ ] me
[Applause]
oh no oh no no come on
we got damaged I didn't mean to know I
didn't even mean to do it okay man what
are we gonna do gosh darn a no the [ __ ]
are you man what do you think what his
name was
that's a nice ass duck one of the guys
we were with this what's he gonna do
[Music]
[ __ ] framerate [ __ ]
like Allah know why
just relaxing put the gun down
[Music]
by a clammy King Crysta Lee Lee is back
it's confirmed it's confirmed Lee's back
well [ __ ] me in the [ __ ] god damn it
I can't believe I didn't give him water
I like no because I thought later on he
would tell us and then I give him water
for some stupid [ __ ] reason I mean it
would make sense to do that right he
could taste he could say please sound
like oh yeah
damn alive all the sudden he's watered
saved everything no that doesn't happen
it happens in fairy tales and I don't
know what I'm talking about even god
damn it okay let's start here
save Christa you and ninety one point
six dicks stop what's with the [ __ ]
frame Thank You P it's a menu that's a
[ __ ] menu what's the problem here
save Christa question mark so was we did
save her technically I think I think if
you this would be interesting if someone
else play this and in the end you get
the line I thought you were dead
or not cuz if she didn't get that line
she's always a line you know I'm saying
I don't it's when we threw the [ __ ]
rock or whatever well I guess only eight
percent didn't so it's gonna be hard to
tell you and ninety percent kill the dog
I mean the dog would have died anyway it
just seemed like the nice thing to do it
is to [ __ ] kill him plus it felt good
to kill that piece of dog not that I
like killing dogs he was gonna die and
he was biting me and my dog just farted
when I said that Thanks
did you give water to the dying man okay
so I wish I gave him water don't give me
a hard time for this okay
I know you bros now you know your
brother's keep commenting if I make a
wrong decision I want to give him water
it's trying to be a good decision and it
became a bad ization just like
everything I do
like accept the next apology I mean why
wouldn't you if you don't accept this
apology then you're a dick
did you save [ __ ] Pete 50/50 that
really wasn't 50/50 call honestly I
chose Nick because I figured he's
younger and I figured he should be the
one who lives on out of the two of them
thinking would have been too sad if if
Pete died I don't know
I honestly don't know if I'd if I change
my mind for some [ __ ] reason I might
just replay this by myself and change
those two last ones but at the same time
know I know I'm not gonna do that
not gonna do I love this [ __ ] love
this game it's so awesome
I I want to thank you both for watching
episode 1 can wait for episode 2 it's
not gonna be out until probably a month
a month and a half I don't know it
depends I know they're working hard or
whatever it could be more it could be
less that's usually what it takes that
was a lot of fun I really love these
games it's so much fun to share them
with you as well so I wonder I really
want to thank you for watching I am
gonna start another series after this
one right away I kind of so because I
want to I just been waiting for this one
I didn't want to start any other series
cuz you never know when this these games
are coming out that really like a random
with their dates I didn't want anything
interfering with this because I really
really am a big fan of these um all
right look like you enjoy watching hits
the sky Cumbre today I see bras in the
next one
stay awesome
you
[Music]